en el momento del ataque había al menos
4000 personas la mayoría mujeres niños y
ancianos que estaban esperando el tren
de las regiones de don exit lugar aquí
en el este de ucrania que habían huido
de sus hogares en busca de otras zonas
más seguras en el centro bueno el oeste
del país o directamente para marcharse a
otros países europeos cercanos la
estación central de tren de klamath
horts se ha convertido en el centro de
evacuación de decenas de miles de
ucranianos de la región del donbass ante
una inminente operación rusa a gran
escala ambos bandos se acusan mutuamente
de haber lanzado el ataque por el que se
habría utilizado
unos misiles
koxka como pueden ver detrás de mí que
son de corto alcance y de poca precisión
sea quien sea quien haya provocado la
masacre las consecuencias es que al
menos 50 personas han muerto y más de
100 han resultado heridas
cuando estaban esperando un tren huyendo
de la guerra para poder ir a un lugar
seguro